استووادلوا
استووا
الله اكبر
الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
الله لا اله الا هو ليجمعنكم
الى يوم القيامه لا ريب فيه ومن اصدق من
الله حديثا فما لكم في المنافقين فئتين
والله انكسهم بما كسبوا اتريدون ان تهدوا
من اضل الله
ومن يضلل الله فلن تجد له سبيلا
ودوا لو تكفرون كما كفروا فتكونون سواء
فلا تتخذوا منهم اولياء حتى يهاجروا في
سبيل الله فان تولوا فخذوهم واقتلوهم حيث
وجدتموهم ولا تتخذ خذوا منهم وليا ولا
نصيرا
الا الذين يصلون الى قوم بينكم وبينهم
ميثاق او جاؤوكم
حصرت صدورهم ان يقاتلوكم او يقاتلوا قومهم
ولو شاء الله لسلطهم عليكم فلقاتلوكم
فان اعتزلوكم فلم يقاتلوكم والقوا اليكم
السلم فما جعل الله لكم عليهم سبيلا
ستجدون اخرين يريدون ان يامنوكم ويامنوا
قومهم كلما ردوا الى الفتنه اركسوا فيها
فان لم يعتزلوكم ويلقوا اليكم السلم
ويكفوا ايديهم فخذوهم واقتلوهم حيث ثقفتم
هم واولئك
واولئكم
جعلنا لكم عليهم سلطانا مبينا
وما كان لمؤمن ان يقتل مؤمنا الا خطا ومن
قتل مؤمنا خطا فتحرير رقبه مؤمنه وديه
مسلمه الى اهله الا ان يصدقوا
فان كان من قوم عدو لكم وهو مؤمن فتح رقبه
مؤمنه وان كان من قوم بينكم وبينهم ميثاق
فديه مسلمه الى اهله وتحليل رقبه مؤمنه
فمن لم يجد فصيام شهرين متتابعين توبه من
الله
وكان الله عليما حكيما
ومن يقتل مؤمنا متعمدا فجزاؤه
جهنم خالدا فيها وغضب الله عليه ولعنه
واعد له عذابا عظيما
يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا ضربتم في الارض
يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا ضربتم في سبيل ل
فتبينوا ولا تقولوا لمن القى اليكم السلام
لست مؤمنا تبتغون
تبتغون عرض الحياه الدنيا فعند الله مغانم
كثيره
كذلك كنتم من قبل فمن الله عليكم فتبينوا
ان الله كان بما تعملون خبيرا
لا يستوي القاعدون من المؤمنين غير اولي
الضرر والمجاهدون في سبيل الله باموالهم
وانفسهم
فضل الله المجاهدين باموالهم وانفسهم
على القاعدين درجه وكلا وعد الله الحسنى
وفضل الله المجاهدين على القاعدين اجرا
عظيما
درجات
منه ومغفره ورحمه وكان الله غفورا رحيما
ان الذين توفاهم الملائكه ظالمي انفسهم
قالوا فيما كنتم
قالوا كنا مستضعفين في الارض قالوا الم
تكن ارض الله واسعه
فتهاجروا فيها فاولئك
ماواهم جهنم وساءت
مصيرا
الا المستضعفين من الرجال والنساء
والولدان لا يستطيعون حيله ولا يهتدون
سبيلا
فاولئك
عسى الله ان يعفوا عنهم
وكان الله عفو
غفورا
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ومن يهاجر في سبيل الله يجد في الارض
مراغما كثيرا وسعه ومن يخرج من بيته
مهاجرا الى الله ورسوله ثم يدركه الموت
فقد وقع اجره على الله
وكان الله غفورا رحيما
وليس عليكم جناح واذا ضربتم في الارض فليس
عليكم جناح ان تقصروا من الصلاه ان خفتم
ان يفتنكم الذين كفروا
ان الكافرين كانوا لكم عدوا ممينا
واذا كنت فيهم فاقمت لهم الصلاه فلتقوا
طائفه
منهم معك ولياخذوا اسلحتهم
فاذا سجدوا فليكونوا من ورائكم
ولتات طائفه
اخرى لم يصلوا فليصلوا معك ولياخذوا حذرهم
واسلحتهم
ود الذين كفروا لو تغفلون عن اسلحتكم
متعتكم فيميلون عليكم
واحده
ولا جناح عليكم ان كان بكم اذى من مطر او
كنتم مرضى ان تضعوا اسلحتكم
وخذوا حذركم ان الله اعد للكافرين عذابا
مهينا
فاذا قضيتم الصلاه فاذكروا الله قيا
وقعودا وعلى جنوبكم فاذا طماننتم
فاقيموا الصلاه
ان الصلاه كانت على المؤمنين كتابا موقوتا
ولا تهموا في ابتغاء
القوم ان تكونوا تالمون فانهم يالمون كما
تالمون وترجون من الله ما لا يرجون
كان الله عليما حكيما
انا انزلنا اليك الكتاب بالحق لتحكم بين
الناس بما اراك الله
ولا تكن للخائنين
خصيما
واستغفر الله ان الله كان غفورا رحيما
ولا تجادل عن الذين يختانون انفسهم
ان الله لا يحب من كان خوالا اثيما
يستخفون من الناس ولا يستخفون من الله وهو
معهم اذ يبيتون
اذ يبيتون ما لا يرضى من القول وكان الله
بما يعملون محيطا
ها انتم هؤلاء
اجادلتم عنهم في الحياه الدنيا فمن يجادل
الله عنهم يوم القيامه
فمن يجادل الله عنهم يوم القيامه امن يكون
عليهم وكيلا
ومن يعمل سوءا
او يظلم نفسه ثم يستغفر الله يجدي الله
غفورا رحيما ومن يكسب اثما فانما يكسبه
على نفسه وكان الله عليما حكيما
ومن يكسب خطيئه
او اثما ثم يرمي به بريئا
فقد احتمل
فقد احتمل بهتانا واثما مبينا
ولولا فضل الله عليك ورحمته لهمت طائفه
منهم ان يضلوك وما يضلون الا انفسهم
وما يضلون الا انفسهم
وما يضرونك من شيء
وانزل الله عليك الكتاب والحكمه وعلمك ما
لم تكن تعلم وكان فضل الله عليك عظيما
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
لا خير في كثير من نجواهم الا من امر
بصدقه او معروف او اصلاح بين الناس
ومن يفعل ذلك ابتغاء
مرضاه الله فسوف نؤتيه اجرا عظيما
ومن يشاق الرسول من بعد ما تبين له الهدى
ويتبع غير سبيل المؤمنين نوله ما تولى
نوله ما تولى ونصله جهنم وساءت
مصيرا
ان الله لا يغفر ان يشرك به ويغفر ما دون
ذلك لمن يشاء
ومن يشرك بالله فقد ضل ضلالا بعيدا
ان يدعون من دونه الا اناثا وان يدعون الا
شيطانا مريدا
لعنه الله
وقال لاتخذ ذن من عبادك نصيبا مفروضا
ولاضلنهم
ولامينهم
ولامرنهم
فليبتكن
اذان الانعام
ولامرنهم
فليغيرن
خلق الله
ومن يتخذ الشيطان وليا من دون الله فقد قد
خسر خسرانا مبينا
يعدهم ويمنيهم وما يعدهم الشيطان الا
غرورا اولئك
ماواهم جهنم ولا يجدون عنها محيصا
والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات سندخلهم
جنات
سندخلهم جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالد
ين فيها ابدا وعد الله حقا ومن اصدق من
الله قيلا
ليس بامانيكم ولا اماني اهل الكتاب
من يعمل سوءا يجز به ولا يجد له من دون
الله وليا ولا نصيرا ومن يعمل من الصالحات
من ذكر او انث انثى وهو مؤمن فاولئك
يدخلون الجنه
فاولئك
يدخلون الجنه ولا يظلمون نقيرا
ومن احسن دينا ممن اسلم وجهه لله وهو محسن
واتبع مله ابراهيم حنيفا
واتخذ الله ابراهيم خليلا
لله ما في السماوات وما في الارض وكان
الله بكل شيء محيطا
ويستفتونك في النساء
قل الله يفتيكم فيهن وما يتلى عليكم في
الكتاب في يتامن نساء التي لا تؤتونهن ما
كتب لهن وترغبون
وترغبون ان تنكحوهن
والمست مستضعفين من الولدان وان تقوموا
لليتامى بالقسط
وما تفعلوا من خير فان الله كان به عليما
وان امراه خافت من بعلها نشوزا او اعراضا
فلا جناح عليهما ان يصلحا بينهما صلحا
والصلح خير
واحضر
الانفس
الشح وان تصب وان تحسنوا وتتقوا
وان تحسنوا وتتقوا فان الله كان بما
تعملون خبيرا
ولن تستطيعوا ان تعدلوا بين النساء
ولو حرصتم فلا تميلوا كل الميل فتذروها
كالمعلقه
وان تصلحوا وتتقوا فان الله كان غفورا
رحيما
وان يتفرقا يغني الله كلا من سعته وكان
الله واسعا حكيما
ولله ما في السماوات وما في الارض ولقد
وصينا الذين اوتوا الكتاب من قبلكم واياكم
ان اتقوا الله
ان تكفروا فان لله ما في السماوات وما في
الارض وكان الله غنيا حميدا
ولله ما في السماوات وما في الارض وكفى
بالله وكيلا
ان يشا يذهبكم ايها الناس ويات باخرين
وكان الله على ذلك قديرا
من كان يريد د ثواب الدنيا فعند الله ثواب
الدنيا والاخره
وكان الله سميعا بصيرا
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين.
يا ايها الذين امنوا كونوا قوامين بالقسط
شهداء
لله ولو على انفسكم او الوالدين والاقربين
ان يكن غنيا او فقيرا فالله اولى بهما فلا
تتبعوا الهوى ان تعدلوا وان تلووا او
تعرضوا فان الله كان بما تعملون خبيرا
يا ايها الذين امنوا امنوا بالله يا ايها
الذين امنوا امنوا بال بالله بالله يا
ايها الذين امنوا امنوا بالله ورسوله
والكتاب الذي نزل على رسوله والكتاب الذي
انزل
من يكفر
به ورسله
ضلالا بعيدا
ان الذين امنوا ثم كفروا ثم امنوا ثم
كفروا ثم ازدادوا كفرا لم يكن الله ليغفر
لهم ولا ليهديهم سبيلا
بشر المنافقين بان عذابا اليما
الذين يتخذون الكافرين اولياء
من دون المؤمنين
ايبتغون عندهم العزه فان العزه لله جميعا
وقد نزل عليكم في الكتاب ان اذا سمعتم
ايات الله يكفر بها ويستهزا بها فلا
تقعدوا معهم حتى يخوضوا في حديث غيره
انكم اذا مثلهم ان الله جامع المنافقين
والكافرين في جهنم جميعا
الذين يتربصون بكم فان كان لكم فتح من
الله قالوا الم نكن معكم وان كان للكافرين
نصيب قالوا الم نستحوذ عليكم ونمنعكم من
المؤمنين
فالله يحكم بينكم يوم القيامه
ولن يجعل الله للكافرين على المؤمنين
سبيلا
ان المنافقين يخادعون الله وهو خادعهم
واذا قاموا الى الصلاه قاموا كسى لا
يراءون
الناس ولا يذكرون الله الا قليلا
مذبذبين بين ذلك لا الى هؤلاء
ولا الى هؤلاء
ومن يضلل الله فلن تجد له سبيلا يا ايها
الذين امنوا لا تتخذوا الكافرين اولياء
من دون المؤمنين
اتريدون ان تجعلوا لله عليكم سلط سلطانا
مبينا
ان المنافقين في الدرك الاسفل من النار
ولن تجد لهم نصيرا الا الذين تابوا الا
الذين تابوا واصلحوا واعتصموا بالله
واخلصوا دينهم لله فاولئك
مع المؤمنين
وسوف يؤتي الله المؤمنين اجرا عظيما
ما يفعل الله بعذابكم ان شكرتم وامنتم
وكان الله شاكرا عليما
لا يحب الله الجهر بالسوء
من القول الا من ظلم وكان الله سميعا
عليما
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدل
ان شاء الله
ركعهلام
سلام
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى والذي
قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى
فجعله غثاء
احوى
سنقرئك فلا تنسى
الا ما شاء الله
انه
يعلم الجهر وما يخفى
ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى ويتجنبها
الاشقى
الذي يصلى النار الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها
ولا يحيا
قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى
صحف ابراهيم
وموسى
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
اذا جاء
نصر الله والفتح
ورايت
الناس يدخلون في دين الله افواجا
فسبح بحمد ربك واستغفره
انه
كان توابا
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
قل هو الله احد
الله الصمد لم يلد ولم يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد
[Arabic recitation]
اللهم تم نورك فهديت فلك الحمد عظم حلمك
فعفوت فلك الحمد بسطت يدك فاعطيت فلك
الحمد فلك الحمد ربنا على كل شيء
ولك الحمد ربنا على كل حال اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد في الاولين
وصل على سيدنا محمد في الاخرين
وصل على سيدنا محمد في كل وقت وحين
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت واصرف عنا برحمتك شر
ما قدرت وقضيت
انك تقضي بالحق يقضى عليك انه لا يذل من
واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت ربنا وتعاليت
نستغفرك ربنا من جميع الذنوب والخطايا
ونتوب اليك
نستغفرك
من جميع الذنوب والخطايا ونتوب اليك
اللهم لا تدع لنا في جمعنا هذا ذنبا الا
غفرته ولا مريضا الا شافيته
ولا مبتلا الا عافيته
ولا ضالا الا هديته
ولا دينا الا قضيته
ولا ميتا من اموات المسلمين الا برحمتك يا
ربنا
رحمته اللهم اجعلنا في ضمانك اللهم ادخلنا
في امانك اللهم احرسنا بحراستك
اللهم ادفع عنا ودافع
اللهم ادفع عنا ودافع اللهم تقبل منا انك
انت السميع العليم وتب علينا يا ربنا انك
انت التواب الرحيم
اللهم تجاوز عنا السيئات
وتحمل عنا التبعات
اللهم اجز والدينا عنا خير الجزاء
اللهم من كان منهم حيا فاعطل في عمره
وبارك لهم في اعمالهم واعمالهم
ابدا ما ابقيتهم
ومن كان منهم ميتا يا ربنا فتق قبله في
الصالحين
اللهم صب على قبورهم شهاب الرحمات
وادخلهم جنتك بغير حساب
سبحانك يا مجيب الدعاء
اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه والتابعين
وارحمنا معهم برحمتك اجمعين
واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب العالمين
[Arabic recitation]
الله الله اكبر الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
سبحان
الملك القدوس
[Silence]
‏Perfect
الله يسعدك احسنك والله احسن واحد
الله يحبك ‏You great
[Silence]
ايوه الله
عمر سنين
حت المدرسه ابوها
كلو
على ابوهاشخليك
قالله هي اللي صامتك
امبارح جينا اهو
لا في
ما كان الله يعني مش كان ماذن والناس
المهم
صواني
لو احمد جابر كله
يا زلمه البنت مافيش شيصبح
على الدور تاخدلك ساعه وبنتها
بده يزه
ضد تاتش
يعني انت عارف انهارزم بقول لي ان بس مش
كنت بدي ارمي على الاعلام على الشرطه
ويعملوا مشكله
ما تسمعش يا بنت تعرف انه بتقطع على فطوره
[Arabic recitation]
الجمعه ب 3500 تعال يوم الجمعه وتعال يوم
السبت وتعال الخميس وتعال الاربعاء كل تسع
حبات فاصلي بيضه ومعلقتين معكم شعيرين صح
والله كل الوجبات اللي بجيبوها ما بتخلي
500 متر وانا مستعد اجيب على حسابي
انا بقول لك للاولاد على اساس يعني
اسالك سؤال خليك ماشي انت مع انت رجال
زلمهش
لما يحطلك السرطان لما تبقى ايده تركب
تشحك
كده
ضربت
لو بتجيبه ب 3500 بتكفي خمس مساات
[Silence]
لا هو هو كل امبارح كل امبارح ماكش هذا
اول
كف
شايف سرطان من اول كلمتينص
يعني بتوقع اللي بتشوفوه
[Arabic recitation]
والله ماكلع
روح تجيب الشارع الرئيسي
ابن تض
هذا الضغط
[Silence]
مثلا
السلام
[Silence]
الحمد
‏Yes.
[Silence]
‏And
I think this one
[Silence]
يعني
السلام عليكم
[Silence]
السلام عليكم تو
speakers
yes no
‏How about now?
Same thing women side. No,
none of them
is connected. They can hear me. Look,
you can hear me. So, it's not what we
think. It's general.
Oh, they can hear you louder.
‏Oh, but
ان شاء الله
ان شاء
[Silence]
‏I remember this went up this way came
back down
‏all the
s
device
[Silence]
‏not
by
‏members there or